ever since he was first introduced in
the mid credit scene at the end of the
first Avengers film Thanos has loomed
large in the imaginations of Marvel fans
now that both Avengers infinity war and
the Avengers end game of command gone
it's clear that the masterminds behind
the Marvel Cinematic Universe had big
plans for Thanos going back years but
just what those plans were definitely
change from that first appearance and in
the case of guardians of the galaxy they
apparently changed quite a bear
according to Charlie when former head of
visual development for Marvel Studios
there were plans to make Thanos a much
bigger part of the first cosmic movie in
the MCU he explained to us for your
email fellows his role would have been
significantly larger we would have seen
some of the relationship and tensions
play out between him and his kids
Ronan's role would have decreased with
fan oohs taking on more when was
responsible for bringing the earliest
versions of Thanos from the comic book
page to the big screen and since the mad
Titan was going to be a major player for
the growing MCU early on when knew he
had to get the details right to
communicate that threat at a glance
early on fellows were setting up to be a
major climax for the MCU but the first
time I designed Thanos was for his first
appearance at Avengers his armor had to
reflect the look of his iconic comic
book origins more being more practical
as well as a nod says to Tory soldiers
in the film because he was going to play
such a defining role in the MCU later it
was important to capture the look the
fans know of him an enormous bulky
purple frame a blueish fabric
complemented by a golden armor and the
shape of a slight crescent moon
accentuating his shoulders leading up to
large slits the longest chin and finally
capped by a helmet that reflects the
shaped language of his body armor but as
time went on Avengers writer director
Joss Whedon reportedly made the call to
diminish stenosis role in the early
stages of the MCU to make for a more
satisfying build up over time that meant
changes to work being done and guardians
of the galaxy during pre-production and
then after making those changes making
even more changes when explained it was
decided to cut Thanos House of Guardians
completely in order to have a slower
reveal of him it wasn't until right
before the shoot that I was told that
Thanos would have a role in the film so
designing him and his throne was pretty
rushed I only had a couple days left to
design him on his throne I made some
improvements from the first design in
which we saw the side of his face as for
thrown itself it's fascinating to look
at some of when's concept art from
throughout his tenure at marvel studios
to see how the MC use plans for Thanos
and his throne evolved for instance into
concept images that when lay board vote
in ceremony we see the mad Titan holding
court on a rocky throne with Ronan and
nebula standing before him as an
audience of aliens watch but that's not
quite the scene we get in the film when
nebula and Ronan appear before Thanos
there's no audience and Thanos his
throne is markedly different as to where
when got the idea to create the floating
platforms are made up that owes this
road the answer lies in concept art he
did for a different Marvel Studios film
just a few years earlier the very first
Thor feature since that movie was so
early in the MCU evolution when worked
hard to find us many different takes on
the movies important characters as he
could and that included this very sci-fi
influenced version of Thor starred Odin
that throne didn't make it into Thor but
it seems to have found a second life
under Thanos for guardians of the galaxy
but enough about the noses butts what
about his face even though josh brolin
played the character in the first
guardians of the galaxy film it's easy
to see that the character didn't really
resemble the actor very much at least
not to the extent that the Thanos have
infinity watered there's a reason for
that explained when drawing the
pre-production phase on guardians of the
galaxy Brolin hadn't yet been cast in
the paths it was on infinity war that
Josh Brolin's face needed to be
incorporated by then I'd left Marvel and
my partner in crime and co-head of
Marvel's visual development Ryan miner
ding did the honors and designed the
version in that film with Avengers and
game setting records and revealing
Thanos his fate to fans all over the
world
it's exciting to wonder how different
things could have been if Marvel Studios
had stuck of their initial plans to give
Thanos a bigger presence in the original
guardians of the galaxy would he have
ended up making as big of an impact so
that Marvel fans can only say what if
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite super villains are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]